hello
thanks so much for coming and welcome to
our presentation today
we're going to talk about how to achieve
data-driven application growth
using finance my name is alex and i'm an
engineering manager
on firebase predictions hello i'm nia
lee a software engineer on firebase
predictions
so let's talk about how firebase can
help you as an application developer
grow a successful business we all know
that building great app is certainly
important
but it's only half a buck you want to
grow a user base
retain your users monetize them so you
can grow your business
so today we're going to talk about a few
key points in your journey
firstly how can we objectively measure
your application success
both in terms of industry standard
metrics and events that are unique to
your application
secondly we'll be looking at ways to
make changes to your app's look and feel
as well as behavior without having to do
a release to the various app stores
thirdly we'll look at ways to predict
user behavior using machine learning
and lastly we'll be able to test those
changes
to ensure that there's been significant
impact and that the changes we've made
are not having any unintended effects
so let's start with a simple example of
an application that you could build
and then we'll adapt it to some more
sophisticated strategies
so let's consider your new app sparky's
adventure
in this app you have decided to offer
in-app purchases to the user
while you continue to develop features
to make the app more interesting
and appealing to a wider user base
as your app develops and our team
becomes more sophisticated
we try to run some tests to help improve
this process
or to ensure that changes that your team
makes don't undo
any of your previous hard work but these
tests can involve a lot of
one-off engineering time which ends up
being difficult to scale
but this is where firebase can help
powerful firebase back-ends like cloud
functions cloud firestore and cloud
storage
allow you to quickly build and scale
your application
firebase also has great tools to make
sure your app stays performant and crash
free
with products like crashlytics test lab
and performance monitoring
the firebase can also provide you with
some out of the box solutions
that can help you grow your user base
retain your users
and monetize them so you can maximize
your business success
so let's say one day jing your product
manager wants to test the hypothesis
that shown the most expensive items
first will lead to more users
spend more money per average user
session
well that's an interesting idea but it
brings with it a lot of questions
what other implications could this
change have how will
we measure success let's start by using
firebase
to get some key indicators for this app
first off we need to add some analytics
to our app to measure
the success of our app now the nice
thing here
is is that you've already integrated
with firebase analytics is already up
and running
and if you haven't just by creating a
project in the firebase console
and adding the base sdk to your ios or
android app
you can get analytics up and running
without any custom code
you get a lot of automatic reports right
there in the firebase dashboard
on data that's important to us things
like in-app purchases
user engagement retention cohorts daily
and monthly active users
and more all of which lets us get a good
sense
of the overall health of our app right
out of the box
we'll also go ahead and record any
events that are important to your
application
whether that's people finishing around
your game visiting the in-app store
starting or completing your in-app
tutorial
inviting a friend and so on this is all
data that we can use later
either in the firebase dashboard or
through bigquery
to answer questions that we might have
about our app like
what percentage of my users are making
it through the tutorial
is level five too hard is level five too
easy
adding these events is generally one
line of code per event back to our
original idea
now that we know that we can measure the
success metrics we care about
but how can we implement this change
part of an audience in a controlled way
and roll back quickly in case it doesn't
work
how can we make these changes without an
app release you can do it
using firebase remote config as the
primary driver
of changes to your app now if you've
never used remote config before
you can think of it as like a key value
store that lives in the cloud
and you can use these values to change
the look and feel or behavior of your
app
without needing to publish an update to
the various app stores
the way remote config works is you set
up a bunch of values locally in a user's
device
then as time goes on when you want to
change one of these values
you can do that using remote config
either in the firebase console
or using a rest api
then the next time the user starts up
the app we will download
these values and apply them on top of
the default values
when we ask for a value you'll either
get the default value that we supplied
initially
or one of the new values we've
downloaded from the cloud and this is
nice because it means
that we can have hundreds of values
wired up and ready to go through
our config but because you're only
downloading the deltas the values that
have changed
you don't have to worry about excessive
downloads or data usage
every time a user starts that so for
instance
if you've gone ahead and parameterized
our sort order of the items in the store
as a variable in the app this is
something we can update easily through
our config
we can push our update to the world
potentially only for a small fraction of
our audience
and if there's a problem you can simply
come back to a remote conflict
and undo the change that you make okay
so you have the change ready to ship but
wait jenny has had a new idea
jay is wondering if you can change the
sort order to show the most expensive
items first
but only do it for the people who have
spent money in our application before
her hypothesis is that this will
maximize revenue among your spenders
while still enticing our non-spenders to
spend money by showing them
more affordable options this is
something we can do pretty easily with
the systems
that we already have in place when you
implement analytics
you have the ability to create audiences
these are users
who meet some certain criteria in your
app
based on triggering events or being
assigned
to various user problems and one
audience that analytics creates
automatically for you
is purchases
this consists of anybody who has ever
spent in your app
one of the nice features about remote
config that i haven't mentioned yet
is that it contains logic that allows
you to send different values to
different users
depending on their situation so for
instance
you can send different values to your
canadian users either for a nice
localized experience
sparky's canadian adventure or test a
new feature in canada before rolling it
out to the rest of the world
but you can also deliver different
experiences based on analytics data
like whether or not your user is in a
certain audience
so you can tell remote config hey let's
create a special condition
based on whether or not people are in
the purchaser's
audience and then you can tell remote
config
to change your sort order only for
people in this group
and you get to implement jane's new
monetization strategy
all without touching any of the code in
your app while this makes gin happy
it also gets her thinking what if our
past
purchasers tend not to spend money again
thus we should focus on ranking
expensive items more highly only for
future purchases
meaning those that have not purchased
but will likely purchase
in the future can we really predict
the future yes you can little help
from machine learning and we're going to
do this by using
firebase predictions let me hand over to
young lee
who can teach us how thanks alex
yes with firebase predictions you can
apply the power of machine learning
to segment your users based on their
predicted future behaviors
the general idea is that as your users
are interacting with your app
the data is getting sent to google
analytics for firebase
once enabled firebase predictions will
look at your data
and learn from the patterns that your
users exhibit
before they perform certain actions
so let's dig a little deeper into what
we do
essentially this is a supervised
learning problem
the first thing is to come up with the
examples to keep the model
what it is exactly that we want it to
learn
the model is updated every day so every
day we take the last
45 days of user activity data reserved
the last 7 days
as the lingering window and addressed 38
days
as the feature window in the labeling
window
we figure out what actually happens and
give labels
to the users such as turner suspender
reviewer
etc and in the future window we extract
features that can represent the user's
behavior patterns
the data is separated into training site
and evaluation set
we fit the training set into a neural
network powered by tensorflow
to train the model then we apply the
model to the evaluation set
to generate statistics about quality of
the predictions
such as precision recall accuracy
etc and then we explore some of these
metrics
on the ui once the model quality is
verified
we are ready to apply the model on your
latest user data
to generate prediction scores
dynamically
then you can target them in the various
products
that you typically use like for instance
remote config so how do you use firebase
predictions
do you need to go back to university and
spend several semesters
taking a neural network's programming
class
no you just need to click this button
here on the predictions console
and that's really it at this point
predictions
will start the model training and
evaluation process for the two
predefined predictions
span and churn so by default
we will predict how to spend money
in your app or who is likely to stop
using your app
but really service predictions can be
set up to predict around
any event you have in your app like
who's going to create accounts
or share the app with their friends
creating customized predictions is very
simple
you just need to click the create a
prediction box in the predictions
console
and then provide a name so you can
easily find it later
and choose a specific analytics event
that you want to predict for
then within a couple of days you'll
start to get predictions that you can
work with
let's say now the ui shows your submit
review prediction is ready to use
by clicking this run use prediction
button
you'll be able to select the threshold
to control the audience size
and prediction probability
on this select user segment page you can
expand graph
of text action users they are sorted
from
right from left to right in how likely
they are
to submit to reviews the probability
score is on the y-axis
we can use these blue sliders to select
a segment
and as we move the sliders they will see
the bars and the data change on the
right
to give us more information about the
audit size that we are selecting
after selecting the segment you will be
able to choose where to use the
prediction with other various tools
such as remote config not messaging and
cloud messaging
and that's how easy it is to use
firebase predictions
now you can leverage the power of
machine learning in your app
but just thinking what if i want to dive
deep
into my data or combine with my in-house
data source
or export it to a third-party system
firebase and bigquery have you covered
many of favorites tools already
integrated big queries
including predictions to export your
predictions data to bigquery
just go into your settings and find
bigquery
integration chip the bigquery
integrations page allows you
to easily manage all of your links in
one place
turn them on and off and get to your
data set easily
after linking your app data will be
created for you
and visible from the bigquery ui
from here you can grab the one separate
against your jaw
and sample data you can also export
or join our datasets with external data
sources
to perform custom analysis
so going back to jane's request we are
going to change that condition
in remote config to now include users
who we think will spend money in the
future
let's change the condition to be based
on spam predictions
then further adjust the percentile of
users to be included
for example only the top 1 of users
who are most likely to spend in the
future
hit the save button and then change the
soft order parameter value in a way that
we think will generate the most revenue
for these users
great news the new cell order for
futures vendor is ready to ship
but jin starts thinking again how can we
be sure that
this has the intention of tom even if we
saw
active in spanning how do we know that
it was due to the changes
we just made instead of some random
chance
or some other changes in our app or
maybe a promotion we were running at a
time
many apps have a variety of success
criteria
let's look at ways that you can measure
the impact of your change
accurately as well as considering any
unintended consequences
of your chimps this is what firebase av
testing is for
ap testing helps make sure that all our
decisions in our app
are backed up by actual data and
statistical analysis
so let's try to prove genes hypothesis
by data
by creating an ap test
let's go ahead and create an experiment
on the ap testing console
let's choose to use remote config
in our case the target audience is going
to be
users who are predicted to spend money
in your ad
we can run experiment on say 30 of these
users
then you can tell fairways that you want
to maximize in-app purchase revenue
as your goal note that firebase can also
check the number of
secondary goals this is very useful for
determining the overall health of your
app
if you made a change that boosted your
in-net purchase revenue
i was so aggressive that it lowered your
user retention
that would be important to know so these
segments
can help you check that in the variance
section
you can add a few different parameter
values
here you can add you can have up to
seven different
variants if you want then you can check
back in the top of weeks
and see what happens this is what a
sample report might look like
these reports come with a lot of tables
and charts
but the most important takeaway is this
line here on top of the page
which tells us that for this experiment
we have 99.9
confidence that variant a which is
ranking expensive items higher
for future spanners will increase both
estimated total revenue
and loser retention so this is great
we tested our hypotheses using
experiments and data
now let me hand back over to x to wrap
up
thanks shanley it's worth pointing out
just about everything we talked about
today
whether it's using remote config to
change how your app behaves in different
situations
or changing how your app behaves against
users predicted to hit some conversion
event
running an a b test to improve your
in-app purchase revenue
or perhaps running a cloud messaging
campaign to tell users about your next
big sale
all of this can be done by anyone on
your team directly through the firebase
console
as long as you grant them permission so
once your engineering team has done work
to set up each of these features your
growth team
your gaming designers or others that
want to help you succeed
can run all of these experiments or
marketing campaigns
directly through the firebase console
while your engineering team
can go off and work on the next big
thing
and your new apps monetization strategy
gets to go from a very simple
provide in-app purchases and keep
pushing more features kind of a strategy
to a data-driven fully optimized
monetization strategy
it creates audiences to get metrics by
google analytics
applies different parameter values to
different audiences
applies different parameter values based
on predictive behavior
and maximizes in-app purchase revenue
through
ad testing so i hope you've learned more
today
about data-driven app development to sum
up
one we measure our overall app health
and set custom measures
we can use google analytics for firebase
two
to make changes on the device without
pushing a change to the app store
we can use firebase remote config
third to predict user behavior we can
leverage firebase predictions
four to prove our success we can
leverage
firebase a b testing if you're
interested in learning more about
anything we've talked about today
or any other user application growth
related questions we'd love to hear from
you on the door
thank you
you